Welcome back to recitation.
In this video, what I'd like
you to do is use Green's theorem
to find the area between
one arch of the cycloid that
is described by x equals
a times the quantity
theta minus sine theta, y equals
a times the quantity 1 minus
cosine theta, and the x-axis.
So probably it's
helpful for you to draw
a picture of this first.
So you have one arch
of the cycloid defined
in terms of theta, the x of
theta and y of theta are here,
and then the x-axis
will be the other bound.
And the big thing I
want you to notice
is you're going to use Green's
theorem to find the area.
So why don't you pause the
video, work on the problem,
when you're ready to
see my solution you
can bring the video back up.
OK, welcome back.
So again, what we want to do is
we want to use Green's theorem
to find an area.
OK, and what I'm
going to do first
is I'm going to try and figure
out what the picture looks like
and then I'm going to
figure out how to use
Green's theorem in this region.
So lets first draw a sketch of
the picture of what's going on.
And because I want the area
between one arch of the cycloid
and the x-axis, what I
really want to do first
is figure out what
theta values will
make y positive, or
greater than or equal to 0,
and go from there.
So if I want y to be
greater than or equal to 0,
then what I need is
1 minus cosine theta
to be greater than
or equal to 0.
And that's going to happen for
every theta from 0 to 2*pi,
and at 0 and 2*pi I get 0.
So we know we want theta
to go between 0 and 2*pi.
Those are good parameters
to have for theta,
because this statement
is always true,
but I get 0 when theta is
0 and when theta is 2*pi.
So I'm going to let theta
run between 0 and 2*pi,
as I mentioned.
So now let's think about
what the picture is.
When theta is 0, if I come over
to what x is, x is a times 0
minus 0, So x is 0.
And y we said was 0.
I know that I'll
achieve a maximum height
at theta equal pi because that's
where cosine theta is minus 1.
So the 1 minus
cosine theta is 2.
And so if you look at
what the y-value will be,
the y-value when
theta is pi is 2a.
And the value is going to
be a times pi minus sine pi.
Well, sine of pi is 0.
So I just get a*pi.
So I should go over a*pi.
And I know there's a point at
a*pi comma-- I think I said 2a.
And then it's actually going
to come back down the same way,
so let me draw the first part.
This is not a perfect
drawing of this.
I don't have lots of points.
I'm having the smallest
amount of points
possible to figure
out what's happening.
So then when theta is 2*pi,
1 minus cosine theta is 0.
So I get y equals 0.
And then here I get 2
pi minus sine of 2*pi.
Sine of 2 pi is 0,
so I get 2*pi*a.
So I come all the way over
here and I get 2*pi*a.
Yeah, that's not maybe the
most beautiful picture,
but it's a good start.
So I'm interested in finding
the area of this region.
What I want to do then is, to
find the area of that region
I'm going to use
Green's theorem.
That's what we asked you to do.
So what I want to do is I
want to pick a curve that's
going to have 2 components.
It's going to have C_1,
will be this bottom part,
and C2 will be this top part.
And we need to
keep it oriented so
when I'm walking along the
curve the region is on the left.
And then I have to figure out
how to use Green's theorem.
So to find the area of this
region, all I actually need
is the integral over
the region of dA.
That would give me the area.
And so what quantities--
what functions would be good?
Sorry.
In order to find this.
Well, I believe you
actually saw in class
that you have two options.
You have minus y*dx
over the closed curve,
or you have x*dy over
the closed curve.
You have one of
those two options.
Now which one of those
is better in this case?
We have a choice, so let's
make the best choice.
Which one of those is better?
Well, if you notice that
on these two curves,
x is changing on both of them
but y is fixed on this one.
So it'd be nicer for
us if we could just
integrate on the curve
on this part, which
we would be able to do if
we were choosing this one.
Because y is constant and
it is equal to 0 along here.
So what you need to do to
solve this problem is really,
you only need to integrate
on C_2, minus y*dx.
That's going to give
you the entire area.
And so now we have to figure
out how to put everything in.
Well, C_2-- I'm
parameterized in theta--
and C_2 parameterized in theta,
if I start here I'm at 2*pi
for theta.
And if I go this direction
I'm at 0 for theta.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to do something that might seem
tricky, but it's quite natural.
I'm going to replace this minus
by a plus and then integrate
from 0 to 2*pi.
Because I was going to be
integrating from 2*pi to 0
and so I just flipped the order
and made that sign a plus.
So that should be fine.
And then y, I already
know what it is.
It's a times 1
minus cosine theta.
And now I just have to
figure out what is dx.
So we have to come back
over, for one second
we're going to come over here
and we're going to look at dx.
If x is equal to a times
theta minus sine theta,
then dx is just a times
1 minus cosine theta.
So that's nice because that's
actually what we already have.
So we come back
over here-- oh, I
should say also with a d
theta-- come back over here,
dx gives you a squared a,
it gives you a squared this,
and it gives you a d theta.
So that actually gives
you everything you need.
Now I am not going to actually
write out all the steps
in order to do this.
But the way you
could easily do this,
you can pull out the
a squared and you're
left with a 1 minus
cosine theta squared.
You might think about
squaring all the terms
and then you have 1 cosine
squared theta to deal with.
But ultimately, when
you get your answer--
I'm just going to
write down what it is--
you get 3*pi a squared.
And you'll see you get a
little bit of cancellation
and it's not too hard
to solve at this point.
Since it's single
variable I'm going
to assume I don't need to do it.
But you can check
your final answer.
You should get-- I think, yes.
I got 3*pi a squared.
So what we did was we
took a problem, again,
where we had a curve
defined in terms of theta.
We had a curve, in x and y,
it was parameterized in theta.
And we wanted to find an
area between that curve
and the x-axis.
And the reason we could use
Green's theorem so easily is
because area of a region-- of
this connected region here--
is equal to the integral over
the closed loop surrounding it
of minus y*dx, or alternatively
you could have done x*dy.
And because I got to choose,
I picked the easier one.
And I picked the
easier one in this case
because y is equal to 0
on one part of the curve.
So I just ignored the C_1
because that's where y is 0,
and I looked along C_2.
I noticed C_2 is parameterized
in this direction from theta
equals 2*pi to theta equals 0.
So that's why I dropped the
minus sign and changed it from
0 to 2*pi.
That's where that came from.
And then you end up having
to just determine what y is
and what dx are,
in terms of theta.
Which we had them already
in terms of theta,
so we could just explicitly
determine everything,
do all the substitution and
then evaluate the integral.
So then, that's all
there is to this problem.
So hopefully that
taught you a little more
about Green's theorem.
And actually, now
you've done problems
going from the left to the right
and from the right to the left.
So you've done a
little bit of both.
So hopefully this
revealed a little bit more
to you than you knew before.
That's where I'll stop.